I was a little kid during World War two
and following the end of the war of
course chlorine wavering Papert ISM
steel them you and where do I go
Airport I do feel going in so when I
joined the military I really did it to
serve my country when I got to the drone
base I didn't know what I was doing that
and tell me anything until I got there
they put me in a small theater with
about 25 other individuals and then they
played a montage video of drone strikes
and sergeant after it's done he's
standing at parade rest he's like your
job is to kill people and break things
and I was just like holy what am i doing
what is it like flying a drone I was an
MQ one Bravo predator sensor operator so
I controlled the camera and the missiles
like that's my job
the pilot keeps the aircraft in the air
and basically we support one another if
you look out the window actually if you
look down there that's kind of the same
paradigm view that we had if there's a
target to be attacked they're like okay
this is what's going on where you're
gonna watch a person outside this guy's
house I mean you're just waiting for an
opportunity for them to get into
location and you're gonna shoot them
are you having the kills 13 directly my
first shot it was a winter and mountains
of Afghanistan I killed three people to
whom were obliterated in two pieces and
one of them watched him bleed out and
then watched an infrared become the same
color as the ground that he died on is
there remorse or there was like a mr.
nation I'm sitting there like I just
watched a man bleed out but I felt
horrible I wanted to cry I felt you know
you feel the this is what I just did the
adrenaline rush I mean it was all sorts
of weird weird feelings
[Music]
you